uh well really ugly scenes there let's
speak to this guy's ivor bennett who has
more on this story am i either explain
to us what we were watching there what
was happening yeah ugly scenes you're
right um that as you say have prompted
some pretty widespread uh condemnation
condemnation from government ministers
here this afternoon uh the footage
showed tipi hotovli israel's ambassador
to the uk
she had been at an event at the london
school of economics at their campus in
central london last night
as she left here she is carrying the
bouquet of flowers as she left she was
subjected to
some very hostile um
atmosphere indeed with protesters not
only shouting shame on you booing at one
point the police actually had to hold
the protester back it seemed like the
crowd were trying to swarm around her
and her car as i say it's prompted
some
strongly worded criticism from
government ministers here in in reaction
foreign secretary liz trust she's called
it unacceptable the home secretary
pretty patel she said she was disgusted
by us
by this footage and we have a longer
statement from the education secretary
nadim zahawi he said last night the
israeli ambassador was subjected to
unacceptable intimidation this is not
disagreement or free speech it is
harassment and it will have deeply
shaken jewish students
both at lse and across the country now
for her partners hatovli has tweeted
today to say that the event itself that
she had been at was actually excellent
and uh that she will not be intimidated
she's also said she's thankful for all
the support she's received from
members of the government here while the
lsc have also put out a statement saying
that free speech and freedom of
expression
underpin everything they do
and they say that this must be in a
respectful manner adding intimidation or
threats of violence are completely
unacceptable and they also say that they
are
reviewing the processes around this
event to inform future planning